Did you know the final book in the series,
Harry Potter and the Deathly Hallows holds
the world record for the most copies sold
the day of release? On the 21st of July, 2007
roughly 11 million books flew off the shelves
in just 24 hours and into the hands of young
wannabe witches and wizards. But as soon as
J.K. Rowling had finished writing the last
instalment of the series that’s earned her
hundreds of millions, even a billion by some
estimates, she started on another book. The
Potter nerds among you will know that, in
Deathly Hallows, Hermione is given a collection
of popular wizarding fairy tales titled The
Tales of Beedle the Bard.
As a thank you to the key people that had
made the Harry Potter series a reality, Rowling
decided to produce six copies of The Tales
of Beedle the Bard, all handwritten and illustrated
by her and set with silver ornaments and semiprecious
stones. A priceless way to say thank you,
you might think.
Well actually, we can put a price on them,
because Rowling then changed her mind, opting
to create a seventh copy, set with a moonstone,
to be sold at auction. The auction was to
raise money for the children’s charity she’d
founded, and it took place on December 13th,
2007, at Sotheby’s auction house in London.
It was expected to sell for around £50,000
and it’s fair to say it surpassed expectations,
eventually being bought by Amazon for 1.95
million pounds.
But even Potter-mania couldn’t propel this
exclusive copy up into the echelons of the
most expensive books of all time. Near the
top of the pile, just below William’s Shakespeare’s
First Folio and Leonardo Da Vinci’s scientific
journal, lies the Gutenberg Bible, a copy
of which sold for nearly 8 million pounds
in today’s money, back in 1978. The Bible
is considered the best-selling book of all
time, with Guinness World Records estimating
in 1995 that over 5 billion copies had been
sold worldwide – I mean it was alright,
I’ll admit the first part was quite gripping,
I liked the plagues and mass genocide but
it all got a bit preachy in the second half.
So, anyway, why is Gutenberg’s copy so expensive?
The Gutenberg Bible was one of, if not, the
first book ever printed en masse, which is
a rather easy accolade to snap up when you’ve
only gone and bloody invented the first ever
printing press. When goldsmith Johannes Gutenberg’s
printing press hit the streets of Strasbourg
in 1440, where he was under political exile,
he of course had the novel issue of needing
to create the world’s first font.
Gutenberg used moveable type to print books
at far larger volumes than were previously
possible, with the Gutenberg Bible being the
first to roll off the press. Reading started
to shift from an exclusive pastime of the
elite to one more universally accessible – of
course, every shit stinkin’ peasant being
able to read his own copy of the bible was
the tinderbox for the protestant reformation
a handful of decades later. Gutenberg’s
Textura (sometimes called Blackletter) can
be considered the world’s first font, and
it was created to imitate a fairly intricate
handwritten style, in use since 1150. The
scarcity of intact and complete copies of
Gutenberg’s Bible 600-years-on has led to
an exorbitant price tag.While Gutenberg painstakingly
created his font by hand, these days, anyone
can make their own font, and there are more
than half-a-million available worldwide. Today
we’re spoilt for choice. You can spend a
good couple of hours choosing the perfect
font from thousands for the front of your
‘Congratulations on fornicating’ … I
mean ‘having a baby’ card. Choosing a
font was previously the domain of typesetters,
but that all changed in 1984.
I’ll admit, our protagonist here is not
the sort you’d expect to revolutionise the
way we write—he was a weed-smoking college
dropout who’d taken a few calligraphy classes
after flunking his normal ones. But when he
developed his initial model in a long line
of computers that were the first to offer
their users a choice of typefaces, he loaded
it with some new fonts named after cities
he loved—Toronto, San Francisco, London
and Geneva among others. One in particular
would become very well known—Chicago was
the font for not just the computer menus,
but those of the hugely successful portable
music players that followed.
That student dropout was none other than poloneck
enthusiast Steve Jobs, and that computer was
the very first Mac, and the music player the
iPod. While it was these devices that made
him rich and famous, his biggest contribution
to mankind was giving us the ability to print
out whatever we desired in any chosen font.
Be honest, we’ve all printed something in
a horrific font – perhaps it was your list
of social mores for your bedroom door, including
classics such as ‘no girls allowed’, ‘knock
before entering’ and ‘piss off mum, I’ve
already got a dad and he’s not called Roberto’.
Indeed, abusing your family’s first printer
with abhorrent typography is basically a 21st
century rite of passage. Thankfully, after
that period of childhood experimentation,
most of us develop a slightly better eye for
what works, and what induces ocular bleeding.
And indeed, certain fonts have surfaced as
typographic A-listers.
Cooper Black is friendly and unthreatening—one
might even call its letters pudgy. While it
enjoyed success in various uses, like the
credits of British TV series Dad’s Army,
the Beach Boys album Pet Sounds, and of course,
as the iconic font of choice for budget-so-long-as-you-haven’t-packed-your-grandma-airline
easyJet. Its use is even mandated in the company’s
mission statement. But easyJet was only founded
in 1995, and Cooper Black was designed in
the 1920s. So what attracted ol’ Stelios
to it?
Oswald Bruce Cooper designed Cooper Black
having been commissioned by Barnhart Brothers
& Spindler, a type foundry looking for a new
typeface to entice advertisers. It’s a serif
font that doesn’t look like one—its weight
(which in typography-land means thickness),
might otherwise be imposing, but somehow appears
friendly. Its large letters are close in size
to their upper-case equivalents, the rounded
serifs are easy to see even from a distance,
and the small ‘counters’—the enclosed
spaces in letters like o, p, and a—give
it an almost chubby look. It’s a font which
looks best from a distance, and so slapping
it on the side of a massive passenger jet
is an obvious application.
Albertus is another font where bigger is better,
but this time not for its chunkiness. It conveys
a traditional roman style with a touch more
flair than most, and so it’s no surprise
that it adorns countless classy nameplates
in the financial district of London.
Albertus was created by Berthold Wolpe, a
Jewish German calligrapher who fled the Nazis
to England in 1935. That’s the problem when
you’re a racist megalomaniac, you end up
scaring away your best talent, handing the
enemy advantages like pretty typography and,
you know, atomic bombs. Wolpe joined the famous
publishing house Faber and Faber to work on
book jackets, featuring both established and
up and coming authors like TS Eliot, Seamus
Heaney and William Golding.
Albertus was a font he built from scratch,
drawing on his training in a bronze foundry,
where he’d carved raised inscriptions on
memorial tablets. It was this process of physically
cutting away the metal from around the letters
that led him to develop such a sharp, bold
font that was easy to read even from a distance,
and with details which looked fantastic at
larger sizes, like the sharp point in the
centre of its capital B.
If it looks familiar but you don’t ever
recall seeing its large letters emblazoned
across a financial firm’s high-rise building,
imagine, for a second, standing on the edge
of that skyscraper. Would you experience “a
rush of blood to the head” or wish you had
“parachutes” with you? That’s right,
Albertus was also coincidentally the font
of choice for the covers of Coldplay’s first
three albums.
Albertus is an older font that still sees
use today, but when things are the other way
around, trouble can arise. New fonts in places
they shouldn’t be are a pet peeve of those
in the industry, especially when it comes
to films. Used well, fonts can add realism
to scenes set in the past. But type designer
Mark Simonson, whose most popular font, Proxima
Nova – which is used by sites like Buzzfeed,
Mashable, and Wired – has a section of his
website dedicated to the use and misuse of
certain fonts in movies.
Even well-loved and celebrated films like
Chocolat, which garnered five Academy Award
nominations, aren’t spared. Set in rural
1950s France, it’s hard to believe that
the town’s mayor could have produced a notice
that uses ITC Benguiat, a typeface created
in 1978. While these details may sound minor,
the few fun-loving type experts among us will
nevertheless appreciate the effort that’s
gone into films that get it right. Oh, and
if you’re sitting there wondering what’s
the damned difference between a typeface and
a font: a typeface refers to a font family
like Helvetica, whereas a specific font is
a style of that family such as Helvetica Bold
or Helvetica Light.
I’d wager that nowadays more people than
ever before will recognise the fonts used
in films. People are becoming more aware of
the fonts they use, because, well computers.
. Having a favourite font is no longer the
preserve of typographers, it’s become another
way we can express ourselves, as a Cambria
man or a Johnston Sans gal—the latter being
the corporate font commissioned and used by
London public transport since 1913, and a
particular favourite of mine, which I suppose
makes me a Johnston Sans gal.
Most of us don’t realise we care about fonts
until we suddenly do. This was the case in
late 2009, after IKEA swapped all in-store
signage from the slim and elegant Futura to
the modern Verdana. The reason for the switch
was consistency—IKEA already used Verdana
on its website; the font was everywhere thanks
to its adoption by Google and Microsoft. And
they’ve only gone and switched it yet again,
in 2019, to Google’s Noto typeface.
Futura, on the other hand, is considered quirky
and timeless, despite being heralded as “the
typeface of our time” way back in 1920s
Germany, it still has a modern, innovative
feel to it— and is perhaps why it adorns
not only Volkswagen adverts but also the inscribed
plaque which the Apollo 11 astronauts left
on the moon.
While the lunar plaque is expected to stand
the test of time, the same cannot be said
for what many consider to be the most beautiful
font ever made. The Doves Press was founded
in the late 19th century by T.J. Cobden-Sanderson
and Emery Walker and named after a nearby
riverside pub in Hammersmith. Doves Press
created what many consider one of the most
beautiful fonts: known as Doves Roman, or
simply Doves. The Doves Bible of 1902 is regarded
as a masterpiece, proudly displaying a g with
a dynamic, tilted bowl and a sharp, definite
y whose tail is a straight slash. Sadly, we
can no longer enjoy Doves in its original
glory after a dispute between Cobden-Sanderson
and Walker saw much of the font lost forever.
Upon dissolving their partnership, a long
and bitter legal dispute eventually saw Cobden-Sanderson
come away with the rights to Doves, but only
until his death, after which Walker would
receive them. Cobden-Sanderson then reneged
on the agreement. Worried by the thought that
his beautiful font would be used to print
cheap publications or crude material, he spent
3 years slowly dumping the font—from the
heavy casts for the physical letters to the
solid metal pages that had been used on their
final book—into the Thames.
He’d take the blocks, wrap them in paper,
and then carry them down the road, often walking
half a mile or more to find the best spot.
There, he’d wait for heavy traffic so that
no one would hear the splash they’d make—he
wrote of his fear that the police, the public,
even the newspapers would catch him in the
act. This process took Cobden-Sanderson, then
in his 70s, some 6 months and 170 trips, but
eventually Doves was no more. His crimes against
the typographic world were only discovered
after his death, detailed as they were in
his will and his diary. Incensed, Walker promptly
opened legal proceedings against the widowed
Anne Cobden-Sanderson, who eventually settled
for £700, equivalent to tens of thousands
today.
Thankfully, Doves isn’t completely lost.
Swedish designer Torbjörn Olsson created
a digital revival of the font in 1994, attempting
to emulate the rounded corners and imperfections
that gave the printed characters so much,
well, character. Another designer, Robert
Green, made an even more polished version
of Doves in 2013, and two years later, he
enlisted help from the Port of London Authority
to search the riverbed near Hammersmith Bridge
and recover 150 pieces of Cobden-Sanderson’s
original type, further improving the accuracy
of his recreation. Today, we’re once again
able to enjoy Doves almost exactly as its
creator intended—just don’t use it to
print salacious letters to your neighbourhood
strumpet or his ghost will doubtless appear
to throw you into the Thames as well.
The neater style that Doves and countless
others followed was first popularised in the
16th century. Claude Garamond made several
fonts in the 16th century for Francis I king
of – you’ll never guess! – France Both
the Dr Suess books and the US editions of
Harry Potter use Garamond. While the font
may look archaic to us, it marked a move away
from heavy, intricate gothic letters to the
Roman alphabet we use today. Despite the far
cleaner lines he introduced, Garamond allowed
himself more artistic expression with one
particular character: the ampersand. Originally
a joining of e and t from the Latin word for
and, ‘et’, ampersands gradually took on
a life of their own, and Garamond’s version
is a calligraphic masterpiece, with its elegant
curls and tapering lines, although it must’ve
been a bitch to cut out of metal.
The ampersand itself isn’t merely an abbreviation—it
has the added effect of bringing the conjoined
elements closer together. Phrases like R&B
look far more compact and ‘edgier’ with
only three characters. It makes its way into
business names like AT&T, Johnson & Johnson,
and Dolce & Gabbana, offering an intimacy
that the word “and” cannot.
The symbol has such emotive potential that,
in 2010, the Society of Typographic Aficionados
released Coming Together, a $20 purchasable
font consisting entirely of over 400 different
ampersands drawn by designers from across
the world to raise money for the victims of
the Haiti earthquake.
The huge emotive potential of fonts, however,
can be used less altruistically to influence
our minds. When Barack Obama ran for the US
presidency in 2008 his team chose the modern,
sleek and streamlined font Gotham.
Developed in 2000 by Tobias Frere-Jones for
GQ magazine, it took inspiration from signs
around New York City, particularly the 3D
lettering that adorned the city’s Port Authority
Bus terminal. Frere-Jones, seeing that many
of these physical signs were being replaced
by digital ones, took it upon himself to photograph
3600 signs across the city, and these became
his muses.
The simple, solid font that emerged was a
perfect fit for Obama’s campaign, ostensibly
based on change and truth with a touch of
sophistication—picture the “Yes we can”
slogan and it’s likely in robust Gotham.
It certainly went down better than his Democratic
Party rival Hillary Clinton’s choice, with
her New Baskerville Bold, intended to lend
a stately, legal quality to her name, but
instead publically squibed as something that
“might have come off a heart-healthy cereal
box or a mildly embarrassing ointment.”
Perhaps Hillary could’ve used some advice
from psychologist Aric Sigman. In 2001, printer
company Lexmark commissioned Sigman to look
into what font choices revealed about their
users. It was perhaps unsurprising that soft,
curvy fonts like Shelley were generally favoured
by women, though Lexmark’s decision to brand
anyone using these fonts a “sex kitten”
(yes, really) was pretty bold.
Lexmark also proclaimed Courier was the font
of nerds, apparently favoured by librarians
and data entry companies—given being a faux
nerd is far cooler now than it was 19 years
ago, perhaps it’ll soon be repurposed by
the hipster hordes. Sans serif fonts were
chosen by those that valued their anonymity
and safety, though that very conclusion seems
at odds with the logic that these neutral
fonts don’t give too much away.
And of course, the study had to mention Comic
Sans, with Lexmark merely branding anyone
that used it an attention seeker. Better that
than the verdict from comic book artist Dave
Gibbons, whose work had initially inspired
it, who called it a “real mess” and “a
particularly ugly letter form.” But why
is Comic Sans so hated?
It was invented for Microsoft’s 1994 user-friendly
home software package Bob. Bob included a
word processor and a finance manager, as well
as a cute talking dog who assisted users,
but it also gave its instructions in Times
New Roman. A hugely influential font,commissioned
in 1931 to make The Times newspaper easier
to read. But Times New Roman was a little
too formal for Bob.
Comic Sans was so named because it was inspired
by comics—its creator Vincent Connare read
Batman and Watchmen comics and created comic
sans to be intentionally child-like with a
hand-drawn feel, as if its rounded letters
had been carefully written one by one in the
panels of a comic strip. Sans, from the French
‘without’ is from the phrase ‘sans serif’
– a font without serifs, which are the finishing
strokes at the feet and tips of letters, which
give type a more traditional feel.
In the end, Comic Sans wasn’t used in Bob,
which may be why you’ve never heard of the
software – it flopped. Instead, it found
its way into Microsoft 3D Movie Maker, released
in 1995, which allowed children to create
choppy and goofy films with the help of a
frankly terrifying purple assistant called
McZee. Despite McZee’s horrific appearance
and the program’s surplus of controls, it
was a huge success and still has a dedicated
fanbase today. It was also responsible for
unleashing Comic Sans on the world.
The font’s inclusion in Windows 95 further
increased its reach—now people not only
saw it but used it. Its carefree appearance
seemed perfect for home-printed birthday cards,
restaurant menus, and student essays. But
then it got out of hand. It found its way
onto ambulances, textbooks, even the playing
kit of the Portuguese national basketball
team.
Two graphic designers, Dave and Holly Combs,
started the ‘Ban Comic Sans’ movement
in 1999. They created their website after
being asked by an employer to use Comic Sans
for a children’s museum exhibit. The pair
claim to have seen the font adorn horrendously
unsuited places such as a gravestone and a
doctor’s leaflet on irritable bowel syndrome.
But Comic Sans isn’t the monster some people
make it out to be either. It’s highly acclaimed
for use with dyslexics, thanks to its simple,
clear letters, and it has featured in some
well-loved places, like the credits of Sesame
Street in the early 21st century or at Disney
theme parks.
Still, the big problem with Comic Sans is
undoubtedly its use in all the wrong places.
So in the full report that Lexmark had commissioned,
Sigman went on to detail the most suitable
fonts for certain situations. Romance calls
for fonts with big, round Os which mimic human
faces and come across as more friendly. But
if choosing a human-like font gets you into
a relationship, what about getting out of
one? Here, you want something clear without
being harsh, perhaps an old faithful like
Times Regular. Lighter, more optimistic fonts
that still feel respectful could be Verdana,
if you need a firmer, more final end, however,
then a more impersonal Courier might be the
best choice.
More formal circumstances require similar
considerations, with a Verdana a fine choice
for a resignation letter from a job you enjoyed—it
may not have been popular for IKEA, but it’s
a simple professional choice—but if you’re
parting ways more acrimoniously, Sigman recommends
giving them the typographic equivalent of
the middle finger: Arial. Ubiquitous and yet
unloved, Arial is despised by those in the
know—whatever the opposite of a cult classic
is, Arial fits the bill.
It was designed in the 1980s as a rip-off
of—sorry, “alternative to”—Helvetica,
with which its spacing made it perfectly interchangeable.
Any document written in Helvetica could be
changed to Arial and keep exactly the same
layout and size. Add in the fact that Arial’s
creators then undercut Helvetica’s pricing
and you suddenly had Arial as standard on
every Windows computer. The vast majority
of people don’t care and millions use Arial
every single day. But if you know, you know,
and you use that knowledge to subtly tell
that former boss where he can shove his terrible
job by giving him the Arial treatment.
So maybe Arial has its place too. After all,
what better use is there for a font than a
passive aggressive email?